china is going through a completely
bonkers situation right now they're
calling it airpocalypse a chinese city
called Harbin is having crazy crazy smog
we're going to show you some video right
now and understand this is smog caused
by pollution not fog let's take a look
ok so again that is smog not fog that is
actual pollution just to put some of
this in perspective Harvin is home to 11
million people which is about the size
of New York City their air quality index
score was a 500 they tell us that
anything over 300 is dangerous to humans
New York City's on an average day is
about 50 I mean this this is just is it
hard to imagine that humans are putting
that kind of stuff in the air is awful
yeah but apparently like the states went
through you know a similar situation at
the turn of the Industrial Revolution
you know and i think that like china
definitely needs to figure it out
because 500 yeah awful I mean it's
literally off the charts I think when
you look at these you know it's max what
you're saying is that China does need a
wake-up call for environmental policies
and so my hope when you start to see
images like this is that the rest of the
world turns our attention and maybe it's
a kick in the butt to the Chinese
government to take care of it we saw in
London the same thing 19 the 50s there
was a great smog and that led to the
clean air act so hopefully this is an
indication that this is going to also
kind of turn things around yeah that's
my hope and I mean we had it right here
in LA and now the air quality is a lot
better than it used to be but as part of
this though that China's just getting to
the point in their economy where we were
way back when so it's sort of it would
it's almost disingenuous for us to tell
them to clean it up because they're just
doing what we did a little bit later
right I mean is it sort of unfair to too
now that we've cleared our selves up
because our economies past that point
well that's a lot of smaug though and
they're adding so many cars onto the
roads at all the times I'm yeah just
there there has to be a tipping point
for it and you know and when you start
to see what's happening with climate
change and because extreme weather that
we're seeing everywhere it's that needs
to be this wake up from all the
countries but yeah and I think that
today you know just because of how easy
and free-flowing information is around
the world like I think that they should
learn from our mistakes you know like
they shouldn't you know they should it's
not an excuse that they should just like
deal with a 5 you know 500 little air
quality it's right but isn't that one of
those things where like when we all get
together to talk about the environment
the United States always wants to cap
things lower because our economy is
different now and the industrial nations
that are blowing up right now like China
and India they're like well we can't cuz
we're trying to clear saying it's like
the factories of the United States put
china sort it well I guess it's some
level um so all but if we're all
connected you know I mean if our air is
all connect from this thing we have to
eventually and they say that we can
still see suit here that comes from
China to so right or certainly what
happened in Japan with Fukushima now
we're seeing the same results of that
here so we have to be able to please
someone write some so so actually the
China the Japan things totally sidebar
but we're literally seeing radioactive
water now coming to our shores so that
should show people that were kind of
connected yeah absolutely up yeah so
just to explain the situation a little
bit more China gives free heating to the
people in the North using these coal
boilers and that's why this is all
happening in the north of China and not
in the south this was making me think
just on a personal level for our myopic
little lives that you know I go to like
Trader Joe's here in West Hollywood and
you know they don't give bags anymore or
you have to pay ten cents for a paper
bag there's no class or anything like
that and you feel like you're doing
something good but then when you see
this do you realize that actually you're
just doing it for yourself and let you
know it's not real it's not that you're
really like the little bag that you
would have taken out of Trader Joe's
actually isn't saving anybody but it's
sort of making you have to be hopeful
that it's all making an impact I mean
that's the whole thing is that we're in
such a dangerous place I think with
climate change in this extreme weather
that we're seeing that we cannot sort of
be defeatist about it right and so every
step that you do I think does matter and
so that little bag does help out when
you look at countries like Rwanda that
banned plastic bags that country has
transformed itself you don't see any
trash on the streets anymore so it can
work but you know when you look at
what's happening in China with the smog
is absolutely terrible even if it
doesn't specifically work with our
little bags and the little things that
we can do here in recycling in that
comes up is there something that just
personally is good like taking sort of a
personal responsibility for what you put
into the world or am I being very yeah i
mean i think you mean it's again like I
think it's not helpful in any way to
have a defeatist mentality about it and
to remember that little shifts add up to
one big shift you know and to vote with
your wallet whenever you can when you're
checking out I mean whether or not you
choose a bag at checkout you know like
obviously our diets you know a large say
and
no the health of the environment so
there's like little things that we could
do but yeah I mean just because you know
11 million people are drowning and smog
like we can still do our part over here
yeah do you guys think we're ever going
to fight a war over the environment you
know like if these things keep getting
worse and because we're so connected
right now and if China let's say doesn't
do anything and this keeps getting worse
and the smog keeps coming us and
radioactive water has come into our west
coast but actually we could end up
fighting a true war to sort of control
resources and how countries put stuff i
think it's i think it's already
happening i mean when you look at what
happened in Africa lake chad in the 70s
was one of the largest lakes in africa
and now it's almost gone and those
climate refugees moved into Darfur which
then created what happened in South
Sudan so I mean it's happening right now
it's going to get worse I think
especially in the Nile in the valley
there and you know in the agricultural
belt I think what's scary is that you
probably going to see in the United
States where people are fighting states
are fighting over resources and who has
access to certain rivers so you know I
don't want to be a lawyer I said about
it but I'm you know I'm worried about it
and I want to pitch to states are gonna
be the first to fight back in about the
California us and then don't go against
it will be like la versus Las Vegas
right what kind of be what's gonna be
something involving fracking right
because they're gonna frack from one
state into another and then just the
whole States going to explode and then
yeah oh my god yeah but that's a whole
other topic hey guys don't forget the
Reuben reports brought to you by Cooper
calm they've got up to seventy-five
percent off pet treats toys and more and
if you use code are are you can get
another twenty percent off that's a lot
off there is a link in the description
right down below code are are twenty
percent off make your pet happy